[Music]
away
we should 10 times much have thousands
of
Jus I know I know
I the
[Music]
oh
they s
for our for this country for the
president and for all those in public
service let us pray to the Lord peaceful
times let us pray to the
[Applause]
Lord all glory honor and worship to the
father and to the son and to the Holy
Spirit now and ever unto the ages of
[Applause]
Ages is so
son Mir
[Applause]
for Great is Thy steadfast love toward
us and the faithfulness of the Lord
endures forever
unto those in dangers and distress unto
those on land and unsea and to those
nearby Christ sacred
preat as a mighty intercessor full
of
where as we together we
cry sa with the Lord son that we might
be saved from for
[Music]
[Applause]
might Z
a
[Music]
St for to ground
zero on the eve of the Feast of St
Nicholas I take this opportunity to
warmly greet and gratefully thank all
those who especially today have
witnessed their Devotion to St Nicholas
but also
expressed in very tangible very visible
way despite the conditions of weather
their
wholehearted support and steadfast
resolve for the rebuilding of the Church
of St Nicholas in this very Hallowed
Ground
tonight millions of Orthodox Christians
and non Orthodox Christians all over the
world will gather in the churches of St
Nicholas and they are spread all over
the world they will gather for vper
service and tomorrow for the
Liturgy we gathered but without a church
we are the only case when we have a
celebration of The Vespers of St
Nicholas without having a church we are
just in an open space but we are fully
decid that this is going not to continue
that way
we have to be as soon as possible in a
position together with the Glorious
basilicas of St Nicholas and the
Glorious cathedrals of St Nicholas and
the Glorious bantine Church of St
Nicholas and even the small Chapel of St
Nicholas we are going to be in a
position to add here a church when it
was a church for 80 years plus so then
we will be able together with the rest
of the 300 million Orthodox people to
celebrate the memory of the great s in a
proper
church almost 10 years ago our city and
nation suffered a terrorist attack of
unparalleled
proportions in addition to the tragic
and horrific loss of almost 3,000 people
the impossible to imagine catastrophe of
the Twin Towers had a result as we know
on our only existing religious monument
in this area St Nicolas when one of the
two towers fall on St Nicholas and
render it into a mass of just thickness
of one foot and then push it down to the
underground this happened 9 years
ago in a church which opened in
1916 a church who served three
generations a church in which
marriages baptisms Memorial Services
festivities took place educational
opportunities to place this church just
disappeared in in a moment and so today
we are still in a condition of not
having this availability and depriving
not only the local community but also
plenty of people of the existence of a
church the Greek Orthodox Ares of
America and the Parish of St
Nicholas remain firmly committed to the
rebuilding of of the church at Ground
Zero honoring the longstanding agreement
with LM DC and Port
Authority on this most solemn occasion
we once again affirm our commitment to
rebuild here in this sacred place the
Church of St Nicholas which will have a
function much wider than before it will
not be limited to be the Church of a
parish it will be a church open to the
larger Community here the plenty of
people who belong to the very busy
section of the city this is perhaps one
of the most busy places in the world and
the people working here in these huge
buildings need sometime to take some
rest from what they are doing enter into
a place of Serenity and have a quiet
time for rebuilding themselves
spiritually and psychologically so this
church will serve this purpose this
church will be a witness of the power of
love to rebuild where hatred and evil
demolished it will be a witness to Hope
hope to progress to peace to
reconciliation among the people it won't
be simply a church for a community it
will be a much larger serving edifice
and holy place this is why the need for
a building is urgent and
immediate
now we trust that the almighty God will
help us through the intercessions of St
Nicholas St Nicholas is known as The
Miracle Worker
saved he saved thousands of sheep from a
shiping he saved thousands millions of
people during Wars and difficult
circumstances his power is so big that
even Nations made St Nicholas their
Patron SA
it's a miracle worker and we are sure
that with his intercessions by the Lord
the Church of St Nicholas will be
rebuilt what we have today is the very
will the very long work with the Port
Authority that will now come to the FR
finally we have just a few items that
some young people are holding there an
icon some pieces from a cabum some book
half bur miraculously say this is today
tomorrow is going to be a church and
that's the
difference
now let me close what I would like to
communicate with you today by expressing
again thanks for your presence here and
I see here the presence of political
educational diplomatic
authorities I thank the cans who chanted
today our priests and the deacons who
participated the people who organized
technically logistically this event it
was not easy under the circumstances and
the conditions of the weather so we
thank everyone for this and the
community of Nicholas the original
Community for their Pence and their
insistance that the church should be the
built as well as the whole Aris because
there is a mobilization throughout the 2
million Orthodox Christians of this Aris
for the rebuilding of this church let me
close my very short remarks by sharing
with you
something a few months after the the
catastrophe a few months after the
terrorist attack I received a phone call
from a
professor of a
renowned School of Architecture of New
York he said I have a surprise for you I
said Professor what is a
surprise he said I'm teaching a graduate
class in the school of of architecture
and I assigned the students to produce
each one of them a model of a possible
church when we are going to rebuild the
church so at this moment he said I have
I would like to tell you that we have
the models we have 15 models produced by
the graduate class of the future St
Nicholas and we are ready to show them
to you I said bring them immediately
they brought them to thees here comes a
big
truck and they unload the models they
bring them to a hall of our
rares and it's really a wonderful work
of these young
people they were the students were by a
coincidence from Japan from Korea from
Russia from Argentina from El Salvador
and of course of the from the United
States we have a discussion and I ask
them and that's the important
point was any principle any basic idea
that was a leading principle guiding you
in preparing these models of the future
Church in unison they answerers yes the
principle of the
resurrection we saw the death of a
church by a criminal activity we are
going to witness the resurrection of the
church it's not simply rebuilding my
beloved people rebuilding is for any
building this is a resurrection for life
for a witness that connects people with
God this is something that really leads
to a witness of a new life A New Life
coming after a terrible death a new life
that is far stronger a witness that
finally and
ultimately life is stronger than death
love is stronger than
hatred Holiness is stronger than evil
and
sin and Resurrection is the final word
for
everything starting with this chch
tomorrow thank you for listening let's
be together
to Father Spirit both now and ever to
the ages of Ages am Oh Holy Trinity have
mercy on us Lord forgive our sins Master
pardon our transgressions Holy One visit
and heal our infirmities for the glory
of Your Name Lord have mercy Lord have
mercy Lord have Merc for
Our Father in heaven
beom will be on earth it in us our daily
for our trespasses as we for those Tres
against us us not into deliv us from
evil for thine is the kingdom and the
power and the glory Father Son and Holy
Spirit now and ever un the ages of Ages
me
[Applause]
for
for is
for for
SP
[Applause]
God be with you through the
intercessions of St Nicholas special
thanks to the photographers and the
people of the Press thank you for being
here and being with us God bless you and
be with you forever
okay me make sure I have these correct
the
[Music]
candra cand
dri George C Bible James belus the icon
Chris Gabriel the
Trey and
chisto the Bell so you two are
brothers okay and did I miss anybody 1
where
Qui up
[Music]